welcome to another Q&A episode of the
stronger by science podcast in today's
episode Greg and I answer listeners
questions about the keto diet rapid fat
loss carryover between the squat and the
deadlift corrective exercises for faulty
movement patterns and much more to
finish off this episode Greg and I share
some great reading materials for
trainers that are looking to expand
their training knowledge and we also
share some tips for students that are
looking to excel academically if you
want one of your questions answered on a
future episode check the description of
this episode you'll see links to
Facebook Instagram and Twitter threads
where you can get those questions
submitted as always thank you for
listening and enjoy
[Music]
welcome back to another Q&A episode on
the stronger by science podcasts now in
the QA episodes there is no time for any
shenanigans or tomfoolery certainly no
skylarking so we're gonna jump right in
the first question is for Greg the
question is from hy dot Freeman and the
question is do you have to squat in
order to reach your ultimate deadlift
potential so Greg do you have any
knowledge bombs to drop on us pertaining
to that question so I don't think you do
the reason I think that is that even
though there's quite a bit of overlap in
the muscles trained in the two exercises
so you know both are going to challenge
your hip extensors certainly both
challenge your quads to some degree much
more for the squat than for the deadlift
and both challenge your back extensors
to some degree probably more for the
deadlift than for the squat the the
joint angles and the timings of the two
movements are slightly different so
that's based on a paper by Hales from
2009 titled kinematic analysis of the
powerlifting squat and condemned
conventional deadlift during competition
: are there crossover effects between
the lifts and so basically if you're if
you're trying to tune your body to be
maximally good at a particular motor
pattern you you know you want the prime
movers to be strong but you also want to
train the length tension relationships
of those muscles in the direction of
basically what you're trying to get them
good at and the point in the lift where
like the the hip joint angle in the
squat where the squat is maximally hard
is a little bit different than the hip
joint angle and the deadlift to say
where the deadlift is maximally hard so
a different link tension relationship
for your hip extensors would probably
lend itself more to one of the lifts
versus the other link tension
relationships of your muscles do also
adapt with training so you know you're
not going to be you know making yourself
bad at deadlifts and poorly tuned for
dead lifts by also doing squats but I do
think that if anything squats could be
slightly counterproductive just on a
muscle length detention relationship
level and then just in terms of general
training effects so squats will
obviously help you build a massive
reserve of quad strength much more than
you would probably need for deadlifts
but on a set per set basis squats
probably aren't going to train your back
and hip extensors as hard as deadlifts
will and so if so if you imagine a
scenario where you know you're going to
do 10 squat like 10 sets of squats and
10 sets of deadlifts per week and you
compare that to a scenario where you're
just doing 10 sets of deadlifts per week
I think you probably get stronger by
doing both the squats and the deadlifts
but if you compare that to a scenario
where you're doing 20 sets of deadlifts
per week instead of 10 of those sets
coming from squats I think ultimately
that's probably going to be better for
building deadlift strength just because
the stimulus is more specific so that's
those are my general thoughts I do think
that if you wanted to squat to help
further your aims and the deadlift if
anything I think probably front squat
might be a better option than back squat
just because front squat trains your
upper back so hard and that's not going
to benefit everyone dead lifting because
some people aren't going to be limited
by their upper back strength but if
you're someone who you know your upper
back rounds pretty quickly when you're
dead lifting and it's not just an issue
of your upper back rounding to get your
hips a little bit closer to the bar but
your upper back is actually limiting you
because you know maybe it's not strong
enough for you to be able to get your
shoulders back at lockout and you're
failing at lockout I think I think front
squats can be really really useful for
that situation do you think that only
applies to people using the true front
rack position because like I tend to
front squat with the arms crossed with
like the kind of cheater rack
position and I usually don't feel a
whole bunch for my for my upper back
there that could be me I don't know
that's I I am a body builder who does a
ton of direct upper back training yes
just as a body builder so that could be
part of it what rep range is do you
train front squadron and you so another
thing I've noticed is that when people
train back squat they're typically
pretty comfortable going pretty close to
failure but when I see people train
front squat in the gym most of the time
unless they're weightlifters they're
generally training at a massively lower
RP so if you do you feel like you push
your front squats as close to failure as
you do like back squats or leg press I
push them but it usually skews toward
the higher end of the hypertrophy kind
of rep range like the traditional like
it's usually up in the 10 12 15 range so
maybe I'm not pushing the load enough
yeah you should just try like heavy
triples until you get tired at some
point and I mean it could just be that
your upper back is strong enough that
that that your legs are going to limit
you much your upper might well either my
upper back is strong enough or my front
squat is bad enough yeah arms of load
well I mean another thing as well is
that I find that people who use the
crossed arm position tend to stay more
upright when they front squat because
you kind of have to yeah like a front a
front rack position if it's a good front
rack position is going to be a little
more stable and allow for maybe like a
little additional forward lean compared
to a Carl start position so like maybe
that's the variable and with that with
that arm cross kind of position you can
still keep this scapula packed back a
little bit yeah versus you need a lot of
protraction for the front rack all right
I think a lot of people do oh yeah for
sure so this is actually a good front
squat tip that doesn't relate to the
question being asked so most of the
power lifters I've talked to who've
tried front squat say like this is super
uncomfortable like I just can't do this
or if they
you know get to where they can do front
squats it's mostly with the crossed arm
position like they have a garbage front
rack and I think a lot of people flatter
themselves and say like mmm well just
too muscular like I couldn't possibly
use a front rack position because my
arms are too big like my lats are super
[ __ ] jacked which makes them tight
don't flatter yourself man like Hossein
rows a day had a perfectly adequate
front rack position and he's way more
muscular than you are and will ever be
so the key for a good front rack
position which which Eric alluded to in
which I think makes it difficult for
power lifters is it's all about scapular
protraction
everything we do we learn pull your
shoulders back so that's how you set up
for benchpress that's how you would set
your upper back for back squats with
front squats on the other hand you want
to protract your scapula as much as
possible that gets your shoulders
further in front of your neck and it
gives you a little space for the bar to
rest in between your front delts and
your throat so you're not choking
yourself out while you're trying to
front squat so yeah just getting
comfortable with protracting your
scapula gives you a lot more room to
work with when it comes to setting the
front rack position and once people
learn that like oh what I'm trying to do
is the opposite of what I do for every
other lifts they're generally at least
closer to a decent front rack position
at that point yeah I remember one night
we were hanging out with Greg Schultz
the the dietician it's stronger by
science on a coaching staff and he was
talking about he's like dude I cannot
front rack and we went out to the garage
and kind of worked on it and in like 10
minutes his front rack position looked
probably 90% better yes from that just
from that scapular thing and I kind of
messed around with it in the gym after
and found a huge improvement so yeah
like people just don't know that really
good tip there now I cut you off you you
were talking about how the front squat
might be actually a little bit more
useful yeah compared to the back squat
yeah yeah so I wasn't quite done
answering the actual question yet so
yeah overall I think I mean obviously if
you're a power lifter you should train
both squat and deadlift unless you're
just a push-pull lifter but if you're
trying to just you know reach your full
deadlift potential
I don't think squats are all that useful
and if anything they could be taking
away from volume that you would other in
just general recovery capacity that you
could otherwise like quote-unquote spend
on dead lifting so yeah when I made when
I made the best deadlift progress of my
life just tossing an anecdote in here it
was when I wasn't really training
training the squat so like I was still
squatting but it was it was when I was
getting used to using raps and so like I
wasn't really doing a ton of training
and raps it was more just a matter of
getting used to doing singles with raps
because you know that's what I was gonna
do on the platform and also just getting
my body used to the heavier loading
because you know you squat more with
raps than without
so my squad training was just like once
a week I would work up to a heavy set of
between one and five reps with raps and
like that was my squat training and most
of the time like through most of my
training career I've trained the
deadlift once per week maybe just
because I've generally squatted a lot
and so I had a lot of difficulty
recovering from more dead lifting than
that but during that period I wasn't
squatting a ton and so I had just more
time and recovery capacity to train the
deadlift much harder I was probably dead
lifting three or four times per week
doing different variations and so just
as a general timeline of my deadlift
gains over time when I started lifting
and just generally applying myself to
resistance training my deadlift got too
right around 600 pretty quickly I mean I
would say within nine months or so of
actually getting into deadlifting and
then it kind of stayed there for years
um part of that was was due to a back
injury that made training the deadlift
difficult but I was stalled right around
600 for probably like six years and then
ironically and running counter to my
answer for this question when I did
Bulgarian style high intensity high
frequency training squatting all the
time but barely training the deadlift
that did actually get my deadlift moving
again that took me from I think 6:15
like 6:05 6:15 to 6:45 so like that was
something like it at least got me
unstuck and then it was stalled at like
635 645 for a while and then during that
period where I really wasn't training
the squat all that much and mostly just
getting comfortable with wraps and
training the deadlift super-hard my
deadlift went from 645 to 725 and like 4
or 5 months so that's where that's where
like 2/3 of the deadlift progress I've
made in my my post newbie stage of
lifting actually came from so that's
just my anecdote there but then also I
think we can look at we can compare
strongmen and power lifters to kind of
get an idea of just how little training
the squat hard matters for maximizing
your deadlift so like most I think a lot
of strongman fans do follow powerlifting
a bit but most powerlifting fans don't
really follow strongman all that closely
and the thing with strongmen is like
most of them do squat a little bit but
they don't for the most part they don't
focus super hard on squat training and
certainly don't focus on it as hard as
power lifters do but they train the
deadlift really hard and even when
they're not training the deadlift
they're doing some sort of pull all the
time I mean even like doing a pick for
farmers walks or like framed
that's like a super-heavy partial
deadlift stones is kind of like a
deadlift ii pattern so they're doing a
bunch of pulling constantly and if you
compare the deadlifts of top strongmen
and top power lifters for the most part
and i'm talking conventional deadlift
here because strong men don't do sumo
the power lifter is buying or the
strongmen by-and-large
eat the power lifters lunch there are
there are two power lifters who have
dead lifted a thousand one of whom is a
strongman who does it did a powerlifting
meet and then on the powerlifting earth
then on the strongman side of things
there's what five or six thousand pound
deadlift hers at this point
Eddie Hall pulled eleven hundred and I
mean you can say like oh well he had
straps to help him like just give straps
to a power lifter see if they pull
eleven hundred you know see I mean they
train the deadlift really hard they
don't train the squat all that hard and
by and large the top strongmen out pull
the top power lifters so I think that's
again just kind of circumstantial
evidence and training the squat hard not
really being all that important for for
maximizing deadlift strength so yeah I
mean if I'm answering this in the
context of a power lifter like dude
neglecting your squat probably isn't
worth it to put a few more pounds on
your deadlift and ultimately I think it
probably doesn't make a huge difference
like you know if you train the squat and
deadlift hard maybe your deadlift gets
to six hundred and maybe if you super
prioritize the deadlift and don't train
the squat super hard maybe it gets to
six forty six fifty so I don't think
it's a night and day difference but I I
I don't think you need to train the
squat hard to maximize deadlift strength
and if anything it may be slightly
counterproductive all right next
question here is for Eric from PvP
Martin's question is keto better to lose
weight I assume that's asking better
than non keto so do you have
a suspicious envelope filled with
knowledge anthrax to deliver to our
listeners right now I believe I do
so I already regret answering this
question because on the internet there's
only one way to answer this without
getting destroyed and that is to say
unequivocally yes Kito's better
carbohydrates are non-essential in the
human diet fun fact
so just don't eat them well IV news if
you answer it that way a lot of other
people will destroy you yeah people that
are less scary I think yeah that's fair
but anyway yeah so Tito obviously has a
very vocal very enthusiastic group of
people that like it and support it and I
genuinely am okay with that
like I don't view myself as like Aikido
hater in fact I actually did Kido strict
for like probably seven months of my
life continuously so I'm gonna answer
part based on research and part on
anecdote and obviously the research
should matter more if you're keeping
score as a listener so on the research
side what do we know about Kido before I
get there the question when we talk
about for weight loss is do you actually
care about weight loss or are you
talking about fat loss so if this is
like a quick you know one or two week I
need to cut some water weight make a
weigh-in and then I'm good
keto is a pretty suitable thing to do
for that but you probably don't need to
put a ton of fat into the diet you'd
probably do this is pretty severe carb
restriction but you would also keep your
fat relatively low you'd do more of like
a protein sparing modified fast if you
were doing that but would you be making
ketones in the process you bet but
usually when people talk keto they're
talking about a long term kind of thing
long enough that you would actually
adapt taquito and you know that's a
thing that happens you do to some extent
adapt to whatever the hell you're
putting in your body so if you go to a
low-fat really high carb diet the
enzymes associated with macronutrient
metabolism they will change and same
thing if
the other direction if you restrict
carbohydrate and eat a bunch of fat your
your metabolic enzymatic machinery will
change to accommodate that so what I was
getting to with the research on keto
what do we know about it well keto
certainly seems to be good when it comes
to reducing appetite
during weight loss if we put people on
energy restricted diets keto actually
does in the research have a documented
effect on helping people manage appetite
more effectively which is awesome that's
a pretty cool thing along the same lines
what you'll notice if you do keto is
that you're kind of subjective energy
level throughout the day does seem quite
stable because you don't have such big
excursions when it comes to like glucose
and insulin responses to meal generally
speaking keto is certainly good for some
seizure disorders and if that's ever
seemed puzzling to you the reason is
some of these very specific seizure
disorders are caused by inborn genetic
errors when it comes to carbohydrate
metabolism in the brain and so if you go
on a keto diet your brain has basically
two options get better at using non
carbohydrate fuels or die and so it
prefers the former to the latter and
your brain does it that pretty well to
using ketones as a fuel source and so if
you're a person who has an inborn error
in carbohydrate metabolism then the keto
diet is like it's like a freakin miracle
for these people the the how rapidly and
effectively it reduces those seizures is
phenomenal now let's get to the more
inflammatory parts of the answer
Kito's not great for high intensity
performance it just isn't and there are
plenty of studies showing this and every
time another study comes out showing it
people say no you had that you had to
really adapt them and if it was a
12-week study they'll say it takes 16
weeks if it was a 16 week study it'll
say it takes 20 it just never seems to
be enough ever okay can I just jump in
here and
complain a little bit yes so the whole
whole Aikido for anything other than
performance that's not so
most most aerobic or anaerobic
performance is going to be limited by
oxygen uptake or oxygen utilization to
some degree or another and just simply
like the the idea behind Kido for
performance is there is quite a bit of
research showing that when people do
Kido at any given relative level of
exercise intensity they're able to use
more fat as fuel versus carbohydrate and
so there's maybe potentially an argument
to be made for like ultra endurance
performance where you know you have a
you have a limited amount of stored
glycogen but you have virtually an
unlimited amount of stored fat that you
could use for fuel you know and you're
not running particularly close to
lactate threshold or vo2 Matt you're
nowhere close to vo2 Max when you're
doing an ultra endurance race it's like
yeah maybe there's something there but
for anything remotely shorter than that
you're largely limited by oxygen
utilization and you get more ATP per
molecule of oxygen used when you're
oxidizing carbohydrate versus fat so if
you are being super reliant on fat and
you don't have much carbohydrate in your
diet you're not fueling with
carbohydrate during exercise you don't
have as much stored glycogen that's
going to limit performance because
ultimately it's just a matter of how
much energy can you produce per unit of
oxygen your body is utilizing and it
produces more ATP when oxidizing
carbohydrate rather than oxidizing fat
and that's very very basic physiology
like that's something that you would
learn in in Ex phys 101 class and I mean
people researching this I'm sure know
that but people chattering about this on
the internet don't know that like I've
dropped that nugget into discussions on
keto for performance multiple times and
it's just like that's a fact that blows
people's minds and it's like dude if you
just read a basic Xmas text once in your
life you would know that that's really
like day one stuff yeah and sometimes
you'll get people who say that's fine I
get that but here's here's where you do
it is you become fat adapted and then
the day of the race then you have carbs
mm-hmm and in that case it's like dude
you just like completely destroyed your
ability to actually efficiently utilize
carbohydrate when it comes to
high-intensity exercise and that's
something that there's there's been a
long line of research showing different
strategies like Burke down in Australia
did a series of studies trying to figure
out I believe it okay let's try to adapt
people get them fat adapted and then
with or without carbohydrate replacement
before the event let's try to see if we
can tap into this and utilize it and
there's a whole body of completely
failed research trying to utilize this
yeah
and they eventually just said screw it
we can't find a scenario in which this
is better than normal and so the ironic
thing is the thing that does maybe work
a little better than normal is taking a
much less extreme approach there was a
study Holly and Burke did maybe two or
three years ago using what was called a
sleep low approach where basically
instead of feeding people carbohydrate
all day and before and after every
workout they had people training twice a
day they were doing if memory serves a
high intensity training session in the
evening and then like a moderate to low
intensity longer duration session in the
morning and after the morning low
intensity like low to moderate intensity
session they would eat carbohydrate the
day up to their modern up to their high
intensity session in the evening then
they do their high intensity session in
the evening that would you know burn a
lot of carbohydrate burn through a lot
of glycogen and then they wouldn't eat
carbohydrate and glycogen replenish
after the evening session and then they
would do the next morning session a
little more kleig agenda pleated a
little
less reliant on carbohydrate with a low
enough intensity that it wouldn't be the
sort of exercise that would be limited
by low carbohydrate availability and
there's research showing that when you
do aerobic training with low
carbohydrate availability and low cly
kajin you you do actually get maybe
better aerobic adaptations
even though actual performance may be
compromised a little bit so you're
getting the the benefits of doing really
high quality high intensity stuff with
plenty of carbohydrate in your system
then with maybe some signaling and
adaptive benefits of doing the low
intensity stuff with less carbohydrate
to improve fat oxidation so that
actually seems to work pretty well and
it's much much less extreme than going
full keto and yeah so that's something
that's been shown from multiple
different unrelated lab groups as well
there's kind of a small body of
literature some people call it trained
low I guess they use the like sleep low
terminology but the idea of training
during low glycogen storage levels with
low intensity training in a program that
also includes intentionally having your
high intensity work taking place during
times when you have Rieff ed glycogen or
refilled your glycogen storage that is
an effective strategy if that relates to
what you're doing but like if your
general fitness if you're trained for
body comp if you're a lifter yes so you
get nothing so just to be clear to this
point we've been talking about endurance
athletes yeah this is like if you fit
within this narrow window of particular
types of endurance activity like there
are some benefits of this trained low
approach with glycogen you could argue
that for ultra ultra endurance events
maybe keto could make sense to you yeah
and I mean maybe if you're just super
general fitness and you know you're
trying to get a little bigger but also
get in better shape you know maybe lift
in the evening
dony carbohydrate after your training
session and then do some cardio in the
morning before you eat carbs like maybe
you can get some of those benefits there
but if you're someone who I would assume
like most stronger by science fans are
mostly interested in pure strength or
physique outcomes I don't see it doing
too much for you no probably not so so
with keto it's not great for for really
high intensity performance you could
make arguments that for low rep range
stuff like you could maybe try to fight
the battle that over time once you're
adapted it's almost as good as normal
like that's something that comes up a
lot with these different things that you
could adapt to over time is the question
is are you adapting to something that's
better than the standard or the default
or are you telling me that your
performance is gonna suck for a while
and then once you adapt to it you'll be
back to normal because that's not a good
trade-off to me yeah yeah and leaning on
the anecdote side of things
like I did try keto for a good six or
seven months and some of it was cool
like my appetite was under great control
general subjective energy level was
quite level which is really nice but my
training in the gym because I tend to
train up in the eight 10 12 rep range
for a lot of my sets it was garbage and
I was like ah but I've heard that you
adapt to this I didn't like I'm open to
the idea that it's possible and I know
you guys save the comments I know you
did it wrong like fine but if we have to
like and anytime there's a study on this
it's always like no it wasn't the right
population it wasn't the right
adaptation period it's the wrong
performance test if we have to work this
hard to find a benefit it can't be that
big of a benefit at some point it should
start revealing itself in the literature
to some extent now I will say there was
a study from Bullock's group the lead
author I think was a Bolex group the
lead author was Mick Swiney or McSweeney
I don't know how they pronounce it but
people got really worked up because they
said check out the the performance
improvement and what happened was
the performance outcome I think I think
it was a cycling test but the numerator
was like the wattage like the power
output mm-hmm and then the denominator
was body weight and so what happened was
they just lost some weight and didn't
completely tank their performance and so
that was chalked up as a performance
improvement because it was greater power
output scaled to their new reduced body
weight yeah and so like a lot of people
were like see and improved performance
and then a lot of people were furious
because they're like no it just means
that they don't have any glycogen but
they managed to get it together for 30
seconds on this test and it completely
tanked mm-hmm but in any case so keto is
it better for weight loss it's a loaded
question it's not better for performance
and training is going to probably be
part of your body composition goals will
you lose some water weight pretty
quickly that will stay off yeah yeah
yeah you probably will and can keto help
with managing your energy level and your
appetite it definitely can now any kind
of diet that excludes a macronutrient or
several food groups and like keto you're
pretty much cutting out food groups like
when your carbs are that low anytime you
do that you have to be really mindful of
making sure you're getting all the
micronutrients that you need and you
know depending on how you structure your
keto diet there often are some big gaps
that need to get filled usually via
supplementation so I think that says
agnostic and answer as you can give like
it it's not great for performance there
are some benefits when it comes to
weight loss you could do just as well
with a non keto weight loss diet and
probably perform better if you go the
keto route you'll probably enjoy better
appetite regulation maybe depending on
exactly what we're comparing it to but
you'll have to be mindful that there
might be some supplementation you need
to do which generally speaking Gregg if
we're if we're evaluating a diet and you
say yeah
it's doable but there are some big gaps
that you got to look for that's usually
not indicative of like the end-all
be-all perfect diet I agree
all right so hate mail goes to Gregg's
email address we'll put that in the show
notes all right let's move on before we
get into more trouble
okay so this next question is from John
there's no way that's a username if
memory serves this was a website common
okay it was it was a comment on the last
Q&A video we did I was gonna say this
question is from John who's the third
Instagram user that signed up if you got
John okay so the question is what
exercises would you based our routine
around for non power lifters so Greg
would you be so kind as to firebomb us
with some knowledge pertaining to
exercises for non power lifters yeah so
I think I think squat bench and deadlift
are are fine exercises and I think it
does make sense in general to kind of
build exercises around that for most
people most of the time just because if
you're putting a program out into the
world and you have the consideration of
well what equipment are people likely to
have access to if they have a gym
membership they probably have access to
barbells so you know squat bench and
deadlift are fine exercises to build a
program around
however if if I were to build the ideal
general routine for non power lifters
assuming they had access to the
equipment that they wanted or that they
had the budget that they could buy it
for a home gym I don't know that I would
go with any of the classic powerlifting
exercises not because they're bad
exercises but just because I think that
there are better tools that could be
used so starting with the squat I would
probably replace it with the safety bar
squat or if someone didn't want to buy a
safety bar probably with the front squat
I think I think front squats
in general are good because I think that
over time they probably have a slightly
lower injury risk than back squats do
because you know if if your form starts
breaking down you dump the bar with
squats you can really really grind and
just let your form degrade pretty
considerably before you actually miss a
rep and I mean you know the response to
that is well people should just learn to
lift with good form but you know when
people are really pushing themselves
sometimes [ __ ] happens you know so I
think front squats have a built-in
safety mechanism where when you're when
you start losing position you just lose
the bar and the sets over safety bar
squats I think are somewhat similar they
don't have the same built-in spotty
mechanism but very much more so since
they position the weight a little bit
further in front you generally can't get
away with as much form breakdown so I
find that they tend to ingrain good form
a little bit better than back squats do
for most people they also let people
stay a little bit more upright when they
squat which you know your mileage may
vary but I find that especially for
learning the exercise a lot of people
don't want to just don't feel
comfortable with like a super hip
dominant type squat and so especially
for learning the exercise I think safety
bar squats are great and then if you're
you know a banged up old power lifter
and or maybe you're just you want to
flatter yourself by thinking you're
super jacked and don't have the mobility
or and don't want to develop the
mobility to back squat safety bar squats
are good because you don't need any
significant shoulder and upper body
mobility to actually you know use the
implement and get your hands behind the
bar see I'd probably replace the back
squat with either a safety bar squat or
a front squat
I think I think weighted push-ups or
like resisted push-ups are generally a
better option than bench press so bench
is fine and obviously people will
eventually reach the point where they're
too strong for resisted push-ups to
really do much for them and then at that
point switch over to bench press it's a
perfectly fine exercise but I think for
new lifters you know if you can't do 10
or 15 solid bodyweight push-ups I think
you should just do push-ups before you
mess around with bench press and once
you can do 10 or 15 pretty solid
bodyweight push-ups I think in general
the best thing to move on to from there
is like band resisted push-ups so push
up in bench press same basic movement
pattern the only differences you're
scapulae aren't pinned to the bench when
you're doing push ups so it's kind of
more of a quote-unquote natural movement
your shoulders have their natural free
range of motion it's going to help
strengthen your serratus anterior as
it's also strengthening your pecs
triceps front delts and then I mean it's
obviously you don't you don't need a
spotter to perform weighted push-ups
whereas if you're doing bench relatively
close to failure not a bad idea to have
a spotter so it makes it a little bit
more versatile of an exercise for
different circumstances or training at
gyms where you don't necessarily trust
someone to spot you so yeah one once you
can do several good push ups with a
really heavy band and band resisted push
ups aren't doing much for you anymore
bench press is fine but I think most
people can probably get the same like
hypertrophic and general strength
benefits from band resistant push-ups
while maybe also being a little bit more
shoulder friendly because your scapula
aren't pinned for deadlift I think I
would probably substitute that as well
with something else with the something
else kind of depending on the lifter and
what they have access to so it's no
secret I'm a big fan of trap bar
deadlifts for a few different reasons
one of them
is just that similar to the front squat
and having that safety valve
if form starts breaking down when you
see people's forms start breaking down
with a barbell deadlift it generally
goes and in the direction of just a
bunch of spinal flexion whereas with a
trap bar deadlift sometimes it goes that
way but oftentimes what people do is
they move from more of a you know hip
dominant hinge type pattern to like a
more upright knees forward squatty type
pattern so it's like oh man you started
fatiguing what's the worst thing that
can happen you train your quads a little
harder terrible so I think trap bars are
good from that perspective also since
you have more just freedom of movement
and you don't have to worry about
scraping the bar up your shins it helps
people get in just a more generally
natural position to pull weight so yeah
I mean obviously power lifters need to
do barbell deadlifts I think trap bar
for general population is a superior
alternative and one one thing that
people will often say in response to
that is oh well I mean trap our deadlift
is basically a squat but the thing is it
doesn't have to be you can use whatever
technique you want with a trap bar
deadlift you can do it super hip
dominant the same way you would a
barbell deadlift it's just it doesn't
have to be so it's just a more flexible
implement someone doesn't want to buy a
trap bar I think our tiel's are great
and especially if someone has more
physique focused goals I think you're
probably going to get more hamstrings
hypertrophy from rdls than you will just
normal conventional deadlifts the range
of motion for the hamstring specifically
is going to be longer even if the range
of motion for the bar isn't quite as
long so I think it's probably going to
be a better hypertrophy movement for
your hamstrings may be a little more
comfortable for most people because
there is an even higher premium placed
on stain and spine
extension and also loadings going to be
a little bit lower so has those benefits
as well and if someone just really wants
to use a barbell for just straight-up
deadlifts not for everyone but I think
for a non-negligible amount of people
low block poles are really good so one
fact about the deadlift is on average
people need to get into approximately
110 to 120 degrees of hip flexion at the
start of deadlift either conventional or
sumo and the typical passive range of
bent knee hip flexion most people have
on average is about a hundred and twenty
degrees so deadlifts are putting you
relatively close to end range of motion
for hip flexion and that's passive hip
flexion and generally when you introduce
a little bit of tension into the system
maximal range of motion decreases a
little bit so there are a non-negligible
number of people who almost like half to
deadlift with a pretty fair amount of
spinal flexion and so I think low block
poles can be really good for those folks
and I'm not trying to scare monger here
like a lot of people and I would venture
to say most people can deadlift from the
floor just fine but I think there's a
non-negligible amount of people for whom
a low block pole is just a better
exercise for them it is full range of
motion like that that's something to
keep in mind deadlift with the barbell
starting on the floor is an arbitrary
range of motion like if you conceive of
range of motion as like percentage of
full joint range of motion for an
individual you know for someone who's
built perfectly ideally for deadlifts
deadlift from the floor is probably a
slightly partial range of motion
exercise for them you know they could do
deficit deadlifts very comfortably just
fine and then for some people that lift
from the floor is probably ace a
slightly more than full range of motion
or at least a slightly longer range of
motion than they
would be working through see how low
block poles are great for some folks and
then so you know if someone was still
just into straight power lifting stuff
that's what I would typically replace
squat bench deadlift with for most
people but if you're trying to round out
a full program for non power lifters
I think push press is great I think it's
generally more of an athletic movement
than just strict shoulder press and it
also gets around the really weird wonky
range of motion that you have with
strict shoulder press where you have
that huge dead zone like right at
forehead height so I'm kind of a fan of
like a weak push press where you're not
getting everything possible out of leg
drive but you're getting a little leg
drive each rep to get you through that
big dead zone and then muscling it up
the rest of the way I think that's a
really good exercise pull-ups are
obviously fantastic for most folks I
think ring pull-ups or neutral grip
pull-ups tend to be a little bit better
than either pronated or supinated I know
not every gym has a set up to allow you
to do that but if you can do neutral
grip or ring pull-ups they tend to be
more comfortable for most people and
then I also really really like Chiti
barbell rows so similar to the push
press not like full-on as much cheating
and assistance from like using your hips
as possible but barbell rows with a
little bit of cheating I find that most
people feel those in their back a little
bit better than super super strict
barbell rows I think the reason for that
is your lats so your the the moment arm
that your lats have at your shoulder to
produce shoulder extension is at its
longest when you're at like 90 degrees
of shoulder flexion so like arms
straight out in front of you like you're
a mummy that's around the position where
your lats are the strongest for creating
shoulder extension and then they're at
their weakest when
your shoulders are in like anatomical
position so arms down at your sides and
so you know at the I guess you can't
call it lockout but at the top position
of a row when your upper arms are either
in line with your torso or like you're
in slight shoulder hyperextension with
your elbows behind the the line of your
torso your lats are super weak in that
position and so I think using a little
bit of cheating to give you some
momentum to help finish each rep makes
rows a little bit better so yeah front
scarf or front squat or safety bar squat
resisted push-ups trap bar deadlift RDL
or low block pull push press wringer
neutral grip pull-ups and slightly
cheesy barbell rows those would probably
be the exercises that I'd base just a
general non power lifting strength
routine around yeah you mentioned those
ring pull-ups when we were talking with
Brandon Roberts I think yeah and I tried
those a couple days later they're pretty
solid yeah I didn't realize my gym had
them we do it's good stuff man but if
you're listening and you think push
press is stupid again I reiterate the
single arm overhead dumbbell press I
live and die by it so yeah I mean both
that's also really good I think both of
those are really good substitutes for
like the standard strict military press
which is very popular but I think
there's better stuff out there I agree
and this is this is gonna be my turn to
really butcher a name so we have a
question from Nico scant Oh Georgia's
gonna go I know that's wrong but that's
what we're going with
that's gotta be that's Greek right
probably we need we need to like hire
someone from Greece we get a lot of we
get a lot of names from that region that
we just butcher yeah oh well so the
question is what are the repercussions
of rapid fat loss and how can you
execute rapid fat loss to minima
those negative repercussions so I would
say listeners at this point take cover
because there is going to be extensive
knowledge shrapnel from the knowledge
mine that Nikko just stepped on here
yeah so rapid fat-loss is tough because
it it sounds nice but from an
evolutionary perspective it is a
disaster so like if you watched
Chernobyl on HBO which I highly
recommend
I know purists are upset that they took
some very creative liberties and made
nuclear power look very scary so I get
that I know it's not it's not that bad
but spoiler alert Chernobyl there was a
meltdown if you haven't heard that's
it's like 40 years ago so I feel like
that's a fair spoiler you're allowed to
give it and give away the end so it's
throughout the process they're trying
all these different all these different
ways to like solve the issues and just
kind of cool things off before they have
to use like be the absolute like there's
like the one button where it's like
shatter the glass and use this emergency
button when you start going like really
crazy with the very rapid drastic fat
loss your body views that as the time to
just like go ahead and hit that
emergency button so that's why you get
so many recommendations to like try to
take a more gradual approach because any
huge acute deficit of energy any like
really major drop in acute energy
availability your body's not going to
respond respond very kindly to that
because that's like its main priorities
making sure that doesn't happen so
they're there I before I get into the
downsides and and how to mitigate them I
will mention that there are some
positives when it comes to taking a
quicker approach to fat loss and so if
you just like dive in headfirst to a fat
loss goal that is you can view it as
like a discrete period of very focused
effort which some people I think
mentally can embrace a lot better like
if you tell somebody like hey we're
gonna slowly make behavior
that aren't gonna cause results for a
while and this is just how you live from
now on for forever I think a lot of
people psychologically get freaked out
by that by that approach
so sometimes rapid fat-loss to kick off
a fat loss program is actually advisable
because it's short term results that are
very very easy to see so so there are
some benefits to taking that approach
however when if adherence is not a
factor generally speaking you would
prefer to take a more gradual approach
generally speaking the only time that
you want it would be if there's so if
there's a lot of adipose tissue to lose
and you just need to get somebody into a
healthy weight range like now like as
soon as possible but anyway so what are
the downsides of a rapid approach to fat
loss being in an energy deficit
especially as you start getting leaner
you know anytime that you have low
energy availability there are going to
be some hormonal repercussions of that
so we often see reduce sex hormones
estrogen testosterone we often see
thyroid hormones go down and we see
cortisol go up usually because a lot of
times when we have this huge lack of
energy availability we also tend to see
if there's a ton of training going on
alongside that people like to usually
hit that from both angles so generally
speaking that is the hormonal milieu
that we that we observe with rapid fat
loss
that's a callback to a previous episode
so the hormonal changes often are
exacerbated when we try to push the
tempo more rapidly with fat loss there's
also a greater possibility of losing
lean mass which generally speaking
opposes the goal of most people when
they're doing some kind of fat loss diet
usually the goal is to maintain as much
muscle in lean mass as you possibly can
so the more you get greedy with the rate
of fat loss not only do you exacerbate
the unfavorable hormone changes but also
you have the potential to increase the
loss of lean tissues certainly
performance decrements can follow suit
and these things are all related so when
the hormonal milieu gets exacerbated in
a negative way and we start to lose lean
tissue performance off often drops off
alongside these things and so probably
the the best singular representation of
that was a paper by Garth at all in 2011
where they took really well-trained
people and tested out two different
rates of weight loss and what they saw
was the slower rate of weight loss was
generally advisable when it came to
maintaining lean mass and maintaining
performance on the outcomes that they
tested and so kind of a downstream
effect of all these downsides would be
that we see typically exacerbated hunger
exacerbated fatigue and potentially a
greater drop-off in energy expenditure
because of that really large acute
energy deficit so generally speaking it
would be advisable if you have the
patience and the adherence is guaranteed
it would be more advisable to take a
slower approach but like I said
sometimes people if you if you have them
losing half a pound a week they're gonna
view that as I'm not losing weight and
they're gonna just check out and so that
that that's an instance where you would
say despite what we know about rate of
weight loss
we should probably ramp this up just to
keep them motivated and interested now
there's also a paper that came out
honest 20-second now we're recording
this on August 24th so this is not just
the most entertaining couple hours of
your week but this is cutting edge hot
off the presses research evidence-based
but yeah Andrew Chappell and colleagues
a couple days ago posted a paper looking
at pro and amateur bodybuilders and what
they tended to find was that the pros
who you know this is observational so
you take it with a grain of salt but the
pros generally tend to diet at a slower
rate of weight loss and they generally
do tend to achieve a better physique as
the end product but generally speaking
when you look at the body look
bodybuilding literature as a whole you
do see that some of the case studies
where the rate of weight loss is more
rapid
there is a glaring reduction in lean
mass as well now if you were gonna do
the rapid fat-loss
approach and there's reasons to do that
sometimes we're on a deadline and
sometimes we just don't feel like
waiting and that's okay if you're gonna
do that obviously you want to retain as
much lean mass as you realistically can
so you want to make sure you have
sufficient protein now generally
speaking people would put that in normal
circumstances at like roughly a gram per
pound right a grand per pound of body
body weight you might go higher than
that
in in this circumstance so you might
even even though that's kind of toward
the higher end if if you want to take
like a really rapid approach you want to
drop the carbs in the fat pretty low and
I think there it would make some sense
if you can get away with it to have the
protein even a little bit higher than
that so maybe bump it up you know just a
little bit 1.2 grams per pound maybe and
that that's not advice because you're
not supposed to make recommendations
that are higher than the RDA so you know
call a doctor call a dietician get I
don't know get the government involved
whatever you want to do don't take my
advice but make sure you call a
dietician that lifts make sure yeah make
sure you call a dietician that lifts pen
a token ideally Greg Schulz yeah Greg
for science comm stronger by science
comm the official team dietician who
does lift and is a very good strong in
but yeah so generally speaking you want
to go high-protein approach you want to
drop the fat and the carbs pretty
aggressively you basically take the
approach of like we mentioned this term
already a protein sparing modified fast
so most of your calories basically are
coming from protein and that's aimed at
maintaining as much muscle as you can
you want to get you probably want to
take a multivitamin you want to get
enough fat to stay alive
I usually don't recommend that people go
below like point 6 grams per kilogram of
fat I know some people recommend 0.5 I
think point six is more comfortable for
me looking at you Helms 0.5 that's
reckless and it's irresponsible shame on
you Helms
it's sick what he's doing out there and
yeah cards are basically as low as you
can tolerate you should still get enough
vegetables in to get some fiber in your
diet in my opinion just because you want
to like stay alive and have a GI system
that functions but yeah if whatever
carbs you can get away with you'd
probably want to put them pari workout
if you want to pretend you can still
perform but that's about the best you
can do and I would recommend if you can
get away with it
not going crazy with the cardio because
that's just not a good way to live man
when you're cutting the diet this hard
the cardio usually exacerbates a lot of
those endocrine issues that we see and
then the whole thing just it's just a
miserable way to live yeah
since you mentioned protein sparing
modified fast twice in this episode so
far would you mind if I just tell an
amusing story that you had not at all at
a fine you know the world needs this one
ok so hot fresh content that a lot of my
friends have have heard but that I
haven't put out in the world yet so this
is this is actually pretty great so back
when I was in college I'm not gonna name
any names but there was this kid there's
this kid in my program who like pretty
good student but I think he mostly just
made good grades because he studied a
lot but didn't strike me as maybe the
smartest person who's ever lived and so
in like February and in the computer lab
he comes up to me he's like yo Greg
check it I was like what
he's like my girlfriend just dumped me I
was like dude that sucks
I'm so sorry he's like not dude it's
sick I'm going to Miami for spring break
I was hoping I'd be single you know my
girlfriend wasn't gonna be able to come
to Miami with me
Miami for spring break you know what's
going down and I didn't want to have to
be the bad guy and dump her cuz some of
her friends are hot I was like alright
well where is this going
he's like so check
kid got some weight I need to lose and
like this dude was already fairly lean
yeah I'd say he was probably like 14 ish
percent but he wanted to be shredded
he's like so got some weight to lose
want to be shredded for spring break you
know that's going to increase my odds so
like don't have much time what should I
do
and so I think there were like five or
six weeks not like not dealing with much
time here so I was like man honestly
your best bet would probably be a
protein sparing modified fast that's
gonna be your only good bet to take off
a pretty substantial amount of weight
and you know just four or five six weeks
so you know here's what you got to do
like we're talking chicken breast canned
tuna
like other lean fish if you can afford
it protein shakes egg whites like you
know that's your diet maybes maybe some
fibrous vegetables and so I told him
that spelled out what foods can fit on a
proteins bearing modified fast send them
some articles to read about it he was
like alright sick I got this
and so they he comes back like two or
three weeks later he's like all right
dude
final push you know still has it's not
going great I I think I may have lost a
little weight but like you know it's
coming down to the final push how can I
get these last few pounds off if if you
were in my position would you just go
with protein shakes or would you just go
with chicken and I was like man it
probably doesn't matter all that much
like protein shakes may have a gram or
two of carbs and chicken breasts may
have like a gram or two of fat but I
mean honestly it doesn't matter all that
much like just kind of stick with it he
was like I don't know about that man
checking the nutrition labels protein
shakes have quite a lot of carbs in them
and chicken has quite a lot of fat
anyway
ask some more questions find out this
[ __ ] has been trying to do a
protein sparing modified fast
on a diet of mass gainer shakes and
bone-in skin-on chicken thighs in any
way so I mean he only had like two weeks
left at that point he did actually just
eat chicken breast for two weeks I think
he lost a little weight but he didn't
end up going to Miami shredded but yeah
he thought he was doing a proteins very
occupied fast on skin on chicken ice and
mascara shakes and every time I think
about that story like I could be like in
public and that story pops in my head
and I start like laughing out loud that
is one of the the best experiences of my
life to this point and he's eating these
ads libitum so it was probably like a
3400 calorie diet right no I mean he was
trying to get in like 200 grams of
protein per day so so I mean I bet he
was eating like 4,000 plus a day but man
so anytime someone mentions protein
sparing modified fast like that's just
what comes to mind and it's great every
single time oh man that is awesome I'm
actually I'm going to not do the other
half of this in the interest of time
okay but I will leave the audience with
a teaser if you want the lowdown the
deep dive scoop on the pros and cons of
slow gaining weight versus more
aggressive bulking that'll be coming up
on a future episode so tell your friends
get them to subscribe like review all
that stuff oh hell yeah hell yeah okay
the next question is for Gregg the
username is because of the implication
which I assume is a reference to it's
always sunny on Philadelphia I have to
assume that's the case the question is
do you still believe that planks
increase hip mobility significantly and
I don't know if this would necessarily
require a knowledge bomb but maybe if
you want
to spray a liberal serving of knowledge
DDT that would be really disastrous for
like the honeybee population sure yeah
so so this is actually a call back so
because of the implication has
apparently been stronger by science
reader and followers since maybe like
2014 or so which is pretty cool so
thanks man yeah so I wrote an article a
while back where I believed I had been
having some hip issues yeah yeah okay
okay so it's all coming back so I had
some hip issues for a while I was trying
to switch over from conventional to sumo
deadlifts sumo deadlifts from this is a
bit of a tangent for me sumo deadlifts
feel really really good to Train and for
submaximal training they're awesome
whenever I try to max it feels like my
left hip is starting to dislocate and
then I just have like shooting pain down
my left leg for several days so yeah if
people will occasionally see me post
training videos of sumo deadlifts and
basically like I can lift heavy with
like good bar speed super snappy looks
like I should be able to do a lot more
sumo than conventional but I can't
because when I try to max it feels like
I'm about to dislocate my hip anyway so
when I was trying to switch to sumo and
and one of my hips was really [ __ ] up
I started like super relying on the
other hip for virtually everything
because I was too dumb to actually take
time off and and get that other hip
right and so I started having issues
with hip mobility and being able to get
in something resembling a symmetrical
bottom position in the squat so I've
always shifted my weight to the right a
little bit when I squat and I generally
don't think that some degree of
asymmetry is really all that problematic
but it was starting to get fairly
extreme and so one of the things that I
found is that
adding planks to my warm-up routine
helped with hip mobility and being able
to get into both a deeper bottom
position in the squat and a slightly
more symmetrical one so both just
straight up hardstyle planks and then
also side planks on both sides and so at
that point I didn't have any research to
support it still don't have any research
to support it but I just kind of threw
it out there to the world and said like
hey here's something that's been helping
me and I still think they're generally
useful so I think I think a lot of the
kind of trendy warm-up modalities out
there and specifically I'm thinking some
of like the supple leopard stuff and a
lot of the like PRI breeding stuff I
think a lot of it kind of focuses around
getting your deep core muscles to
activate and do something and kind of
the mental model that I work with is I
think that one of your nervous systems
main goals is to protect the nervous
system and not allow like great harm to
come to your spinal column and something
I have found is that when you do
something to kind of get your core
muscles firing so you're able to support
your spine a little bit better
everything downstream of that tends to
work a little bit smoother so here I'm
thinking like you know hip mobility and
like force output from your legs there's
there's actually a growing body of
research looking at intra-abdominal
pressure and how that affects like
muscle activation in your legs and also
like force output seems to be pretty
good stuff so yeah I think that um I
don't think that that planks
you know longitudinally increase hip
mobility like they're not going to do
anything to change the maximal fascicle
length of your hamstrings but I do think
that for a lot of people especially who
have sedentary jobs and sit most of the
day I do think that just doing a cup
quick sets of planks can be useful to
add into your warm-up routine to help
start getting your lower body a little
bit more lubricated and you know just
get the range of motion that you should
have that maybe your nervous system
isn't allowing you possibly for the
purpose of protecting your spine like
that that to be clear is the mental
model I work with I don't know if that's
how it actually works physiologically
but yeah planks and especially side
planks I find are really useful both for
me and a lot of the people I've
recommended them to or recommended to do
them have also said like oh yeah I work
an office job I said all day do some
plank squats feel better so yeah it's
not gonna be a night and day difference
but I think it's at least worth a shot
for most people all right
so we have a question from Warren M
fitness probably Warren Moon I wish it
was Warren G now Warren Moon legendary
quarterback a huge fan thanks for
listening Warren
yeah but Warren G was the chief of the
regulator's all right but it's not
Warren G fitness I know I said I wish it
was okay if Aaron had a Merrick I'm a
literal guy I'm sorry I don't like to
joke around okay so question from Warren
M fitness is what is the best way to
track daily energy expenditure for
optimal accuracy so should you go with
the Fitbit etc so you know this this I
feel is a question you're going to be
able to share a lot of knowledge on both
with Warren in fitness and his entire
city so would you like to dust or an M's
city with several kilos of knowledge
botulinum toxin with the knowledge that
only roughly 200 nanograms is necessary
to be lethal if inhaled it kind of makes
knowledge bombs look really
insignificant and can
paracin yeah so that's a lot of pressure
but I'll do my best
there was a a review paper by Feehan at
all in 2018 so it came out more than two
days ago which by our standards is old
news but nobody published anything in
the last week on this so it looked at a
bunch of different kind of commercially
available fitness trackers and and how
they did in terms of estimating energy
expenditure and frankly they don't do
that great of a job so if you want if
you're looking for something that at the
individual level is something that is
affordable commercially available and
will tell you day-to-day exactly how
many calories you burned they just don't
do a good enough job of that to really
feel super enthusiastic about the
results they do a pretty good job with
heartrate but when it comes to energy
expenditure they don't do as good a job
as you'd like now they probably do good
enough for making like group level
estimations but that's not really
helpful to the consumer they probably
give you a good idea of generally
speaking like are you remarkably
sedentary or are you remarkably active
but I don't think that's the level of
precision that a lot of people are
looking for and I don't think that's the
level of precision that people are I
don't think people are interpreting the
number that way when they get it so it's
it's not as sharp and precise in number
as a lot of people are hoping or
thinking another non-negligible factor
is if this were me and if or if it were
just about anybody that I associate with
closely looking at that number every day
even if it were perfect would drive us
insane like you eat I would feel like I
was just like a hamster on a wheel just
constantly trying to stay more and more
active and so another thing I would add
as well is I don't know if fitbit's
algorithm has gotten better and like
this just the software it's working with
but I remember maybe like a couple years
ago like when the Fitbit craze was
really hitting and everyone who was into
fitness was starting to get a Fitbit I
would see pictures that people would
post on Instagram and Facebook all the
time where someone had like taking a
picture of a number on their Fitbit to
show like oh look how many calories I
burned in my workout and it was like a
resistance training workout and people
would say they burn like 2300 calories
no you [ __ ] done it like not even
close so like in in their their
algorithms for resistance training
specifically may have gotten better but
like ultimately it's it's looking at
heart rate and it's trying to
extrapolate energy expenditure from
heart rate like that that's the biggest
thing it does and the the calorie
expenditure per unit of heart rate
elevation is maximized with aerobic
training so if you're like cycling or
running and your heart rate is getting
up to 180 190 you're burning a bunch of
calories if you're resistance training
and your heart rates getting up to 180
190 and you know staying elevated
between sets like you are still burning
substantially more calories than you
would at rest but you're not burning as
many calories as you would have been
where your heart rate that high when
doing aerobic training so I think that
at least fitbit's used to pretty
massively overestimate energy
expenditure from resistance training and
they may have gotten better but I I
don't think there's really quite enough
data relating heart rate to calorie
expenditure and resistance training for
me to feel confident that those
algorithms are particularly good yet
yeah and I think there are some devices
on the market that are purely heartrate
based and I think there are some that do
accelerometry but well I still don't
think that would do that much for you
because for example if you do like a
really hard set of leg press that's
gonna burn a significant number of
calories like the we're not talking like
three four hundred calories but it's
probably going to burn about as many
calories as a similarly hard set of
wotz at least something comparable but
the accelerometer would say you haven't
moved in your lane here you know yeah
what I think I think those devices
integrate both yeah but again it brings
up a good point of like I don't care how
much of a math whiz you are without
someone putting in the information like
hey by the way I did some leg press like
I don't know how you could tweak those
algorithms to perfectly deal with that
yeah whether you're going with just
heart rate or just accelerometry or both
it presents a very unique challenge of
trying to use those inputs and figure
out how much energy a person spent in a
day yeah I mean it is an inherently
challenging thing to do now you
mentioned the possibility of the
algorithms could have gotten better
since the last time you looked into it
they're probably tweaking that thing
around the clock and making it better
your year-over-year but even to where
it's at now I don't feel like I don't
feel like it would be as precise
currently as you'd want it to be for
individual use I honestly don't know
about that I mean I'm sure they are
updating it and tweaking it and
improving it but I don't have that much
faith just in their basic technology yet
so maybe like 18 months or two years ago
or so we had Eddie Joe write an article
for mass about the reliability of one of
these devices I forget which one it was
and I was so yeah like that was a little
while ago I'm sure things have improved
since then but just the basic technology
that they used to track heart rate
wasn't good so so essentially it was
really really accurate for tracking
heart rate at rest and during very low
intensity exercise but during
high-intensity exercise it was pretty
garbage a tracking heart rate which you
know most of the time when someone's
using a Fitbit or at least often they're
interested in tracking how their
exercise is going so like one of the
core parts of its functionality when it
was a product that had already been on
the market for a few years already
didn't were
or like still didn't work for one of the
main things it was supposed to do which
was track heart rate during exercise so
yeah I mean like I'm I'm sure it's
better but like it used to be kind of
pretty bad so better than bad probably
still isn't great yeah and I don't think
we disagree there
I'm just nicer than you are fair and so
yeah I still like I was saying I I still
don't think it's at a point and I don't
I wouldn't even forecast a time where I
would say definitely go for it cuz it's
going to be precise enough but I do
think that certainly they're at least
making changes so that the reason I
bring it up is if you see something
estimating its reliability in 2016
that's probably not where it's at now
that doesn't really speak to where the
ceiling is necessarily but whom they're
probably improving it to some extent
over time but the question is when they
start improving it to the point on the
algorithm side that they're
asymptotically approaching the ceiling
of what they can do with that basic
technology mm-hmm then that's where it's
gonna just you're just stuck with what
you got and I I don't know where we're
at on that curve I have no idea yeah I
mean I think the the the thing I'm
skeptical of is just that it's reading
your pulse from your wrist mm-hmm
because like those aren't those aren't
huge blood vessels and also like unless
you have so if you have the the watch or
the device cinched super tight that
could theoretically occlude blood flow
which is an ideal if you have it a
little bit looser especially if you're
like running or or moving around
vigorously the device can move around
and so maybe the little green laser
thing isn't staying perfectly over the
blood vessels that you would want it to
and so I think like I think that there's
just inherent issues in the tech like
like you were talking about like it will
eventually approach as good as the tech
will allow it to be yeah but I mean I
think there's a reason why in research
we still use the chest straps for
monitoring heart rate like the the wrist
worn devices are
they're not great and I I'm skeptical
that they'll ever be super great yeah
now do you remember several decades ago
there was a fashion trend where you
would put on like only part of a
turtleneck and it looked like you were
wearing a turtleneck no it was a thing
it was like if you want to make it look
like you were wearing a turtleneck under
your outfit but you don't want to wear a
full turtleneck here is this they should
just get back to those and then do like
a carotid for all of those measurements
sure like that would be the better way
to do it get rid of the chest strap -
sure why not
all right so basically Greg and I both
are pretty much out of consensus here
whatever number you're getting out of
that whether you want to blame it on the
tech or the algorithm or both it's
probably not as precise as what what
you're going to be using it to make
decisions about yeah so so that that
would be not ideal so what I usually
recommend the people to to put something
pragmatic and actionable on to this
question would be I tend to focus more
on step counts as best you can estimate
them because there's issues with that as
well okay I think we I feel more
comfortable estimating step count over
an exact number of calories you burn
throughout a day there are still huge
issues there I'll acknowledge but step
count and more importantly just
behaviors like I think we're pretty good
at intuitively knowing if we have become
substantially more or less sedentary
than we used to be it's a lot easier to
say you know what
in the morning I do a walk in the
evening I do a walk here's my route and
generally speaking you're gonna have
your activity level pretty much
standardized there and if you need to
increase it you can increase it and you
can do it based on the route that you
walk you can do it based on the time
spent walking but you know Helm's and I
wrote something years ago about
non-exercise activity thermogenesis and
I put in kind of a joking line about
like I mean unless you're just gonna be
like a hamster on a wheel and just
always be moving you know we're limited
in term
how much we can do about it and he was
like I feel like people are gonna take
that literally and so when we pulled it
out because I've made some joking
recommendation if like we'll just always
move and he's like no people are gonna
think you're serious so I I don't stocks
for treadmill desks go up to thousand
percent yeah based on your
recommendation he was right yeah I mean
people have kind of gone that direction
of like making these things it's like
well how could you just always be moving
mm-hmm so it's really it's tricky
because there's a give-and-take you want
to psychologically not drive yourself
insane while making sure you still have
some idea of hitting adequate activity
level throughout the day to keep your
energy expenditure within a working
reasonable range but I think you can do
that without going the tech route and
opening yourself up to over interpreting
numbers with a pretty sizable margin of
error I think you're probably better off
psychologically and in terms of actually
quantifying your activity level sticking
to some more basic things time spent
walking distance spent walking maybe you
can lean on your step count a little bit
with whatever device you use for that
but I think that's about the best we can
do for now know for sure and if I can
give a practical recommendation for step
counting a lot of people use their
phones they're also somewhat prone to
error what I would what I would
recommend is getting an ankle in ankle
worn pedometer that's going to one be
more accurate and two if you ever find
yourself in a conversation you don't
particularly want to be in you can point
your ecole worn pedometer and tell the
person it's a device you wear to make
sure you never get within 500 yards of a
school that's a good way to in that
conversation get you out of
uncomfortable situations so that's less
of a fitness tip and more of just a life
tip they also do make you probably
remember this from your baseball days
they make little automated devices yeah
they're manual devices yeah just click
it and it you can count how many pitches
somebody threw yeah you could just carry
one of those and count your steps
manually throughout the day as you're
running total you just want to make sure
it has at least five did
you want to get up at least into the ten
thousands or at least have the ability
to count that out alright the next
question is for Greg and it's from clay
Coppinger the question is what is the
best resource for someone looking for
corrective exercises for their
particular faulty movement pattern so
Greg would you I mean this is a big one
a lot of people ask about these there's
some buzzwords in there we're talking
about movement patterns and corrective
exercises I think this does necessitate
a nuclear knowledge bomb if you'd be so
kind
absolutely so I think I think I will
answer your question with two questions
the first is what do you mean by
corrective exercise and the second is
what do you mean by faulty movement
pattern so not to be too much of a cagey
little [ __ ] but I think that what is an
aggressive way it's it's a derogatory
statement aimed at myself there's no
other victims here that's true but yeah
so I I think that I think that these are
buzzwords that get thrown around a lot
in the fitness space and in general I'm
skeptical of anything purporting to be a
corrective exercise that is not in
exercise prescribed by a physical
therapist to treat a specific diagnosed
musculoskeletal condition otherwise I
think it's generally a buzzword that is
being thrown around to perpetuate the
idea that humans are fragile and made of
glass and that if you're not moving in
some particular way that someone who has
like an idealized view of biomechanics
views as optimal like if you're not
doing exactly that then you're gonna
[ __ ] yourself up and there's just not
much if any evidence for that so in
general I think you adapt to what you
typically do and generally things are
fine
I think that there are probably
situations where some movement patterns
are likely to be more injurious than
others so you know if someone's doing
single leg landings or cutting like if
they're a a like field sport athlete and
they're doing that with a lot of
functional Neve algis probably not good
like that's probably not great for ACL
like non contact ACL tear risk or if
someone is lifting with just a
tremendous amount of spinal flexion I
think that's probably not the best idea
either
but beyond like just some some basic
things like that I would be very very
hesitant to refer to something as a
faulty movement pattern and then as far
as corrective exercise goes again I
think I would be skeptical of the
corrective exercise implies you're
fixing something that's wrong and
generally things aren't as wrong as
people think they are so so like unless
again you're you're using a tremendous
amount of knee valgus or a tremendous
amount of spinal flexion and what you're
doing isn't causing you pain or
discomfort I would be hesitant to call
it a faulty movement pattern in the
first place but I think I think in
general if you're kind of concerned
maybe with just like lifting from an
aesthetic perspective where like maybe
you video yourself and you're like man
that doesn't look the way I feel like
it's supposed to or like maybe you you
are doing something and getting a little
discomfort from it and you know that if
you could use another technique it may
be a little bit more comfortable
I can still hopefully give some
practical recommendations for that so
the first thing I think the first
question is whatever your idealized good
form is the first question is can you do
it in the first place so you know are
they positioned
that you can get into with either no
loads or very light loads or are they
just positions that maybe you don't have
the mobility for in the first place if
they are positions that you can get into
but maybe as you start loading them your
techniques start shifting then I think
one of the things to do is just start by
practicing those techniques with lighter
loads and then also use a little bit of
logic to maybe see what muscles could be
limiting you from maintaining that
technique as loads get heavier and then
address those lagging muscles so for
example maybe when you squat up to 70 80
percent of your max your squats look
pretty good and then when they get
pretty heavy you shift to like a crazy
hip dominant super good morning type
squat you've you you view that as a
faulty movement pattern and you want to
fix it well what's going on there is
when your knees are when your hips shift
back and put you in that good morning
position your knees are also shifting
back that's pretty substantially
decreasing the external knee extension
moment arm
Earnie flexion moment arm imposed by the
load and so I think that's a pretty
clear indication in that case that your
quads are probably weak and so you're
shifting more of the load to the
stronger muscles and your hip extensors
and so in that case like I think the way
to fix that quote-unquote faulty
movement pattern would probably just be
to get your quads stronger so they can
stand up to heavier loads and I think
you can use that general type of
troubleshooting process for for most
exercises if you have what you're
terming a faulty movement pattern
because you simply can't get into the
positions that you would need to get in
to do it you know maybe you just have
poor mobility and just generally working
on stretching and improving mobility
over time will help with that or it
could just be that it's a range of
motion that your bone structure doesn't
allow for so as I mentioned before
earlier in this episode the
average passive bent knee hip range of
motion that people typically have is
somewhere close to the hip range of
motion that people need to do deadlifts
from the floor or also to squat below
parallel like the the maximum hip
flexion is relatively similar so it
could just be a situation where your
body doesn't allow you to get in the
positions that you would need to to use
the form that you would want to use and
maybe it's not because you have tight
muscles maybe your joints just don't
allow for it so you know maybe in that
case you just kind of have to suck it up
and maybe not deadlift from the floor
and maybe not squat below parallel and
that's fine like it's not ideal if
you're trying to be a competitive power
lifter but if that is the case for you
that's possibly an indication that
competing and powerlifting may not be a
great thing for you to do and then I
think the yeah like those would be my
general recommendations so you know
first off just look to see whether you
can get into positions in the first
place
if you can't try to see if it's like a
muscular thing or a bony thing if it's
just you have some tight muscles work on
strengthening them if you can get in
those positions but you start breaking
down under load just start by practicing
the technique that you want to acquire
with loads that allow you to use that
technique try to build up gradually over
time until the loads you can use good
technique with are something relatively
close to your max loads if it seems to
be loading is exacerbating technique
issues try to see if there's a specific
muscular weakness that could be causing
that that you can target and work on
improving and then the last thing is
like you know maybe most of the time
your technique is good and it's what you
want it to be but when you go for true
one rep maxes things start breaking down
at that point I don't think there's too
much you can do like at a max you're
you're maxed out like something's got to
give
there is a weak link in the chain
somewhere like it's pretty unlikely that
all of your muscles are going to hit
their maximum capacity at the exact same
time so like yeah as you're approaching
a max like a lot so for some people
their maxes look just as good as like a
single at 90% but like some people I
think just their maxes are ugly and
they're kind of always gonna be ugly and
and that's just how it is so I mean yeah
if your technique is generally good
until you go for a max it's potentially
worth just experimenting with doing more
maxes and training to see if it's less
of a muscular thing and more of just a
you know hitting a 1 rep max as a skill
you're not good at because you haven't
done it much type thing and maybe your
technique at max will improve if you do
max more maybe it won't but I'm a little
bit less concerned if someone is just
having technique breakdown because
they're going for Max's like that's
that's not uncommon and I don't think
that's indicative of anything wrong so
yeah those are my general thoughts but I
think the biggest point I want to make
here is that don't be too Swift to refer
to something as a faulty movement
pattern like I've tried I've tried to
say like a quote-unquote faulty movement
pattern every time I've used that phrase
when answering this question cuz most of
the time like your movement patterns
aren't as faulty as you think they are
human bodies are pretty resilient and
tend to adapt to the stresses you put
them through and if you think you have
like an actual faulty movement pattern
that is causing pain and may be
injurious talk to a physical therapist
about that and if you're looking for
corrective exercises again get those
from the people who actually went to
school to know what corrective exercises
to prescribe which again would be
physical therapists well that knowledge
bomb was certainly of nuclear
proportions and presumably there's bound
to be some kind of nuclear knowledge
fall
so there's two remaining questions
they're kind of related so I'm gonna ask
them at the same time so the first one
is from 0 to fit Journal and it's
basically I want to start out in the
fitness industry as a trainer what are
some of the best reading materials and
courses you'd recommend for me to start
out with for nutrition and program
design the second question is related
but it's more from the academic
perspective so this one one is from CPT
Harrison and the question is as someone
who wants to get into exercise science
at university what are some of the
biggest tips you can give a newbie who's
wanting to get big brain so for trainers
and for people who want to enter the
academic field how do they make that
happen yeah so I think we're both going
to take both of these but I'll I'll
start with the first one so if you want
to get into training you'll want to read
some stuff to know how to be a good
trainer I would recommend the art and
science of lifting which you can buy it
stronger by science calm I would
recommend subscribing to mass monthly
applications in strength sport which you
can do so from stronger by science calm
and honestly I think that covers your
bases I can't think of anything else
that someone would possibly need to to
equip them to be a trainer well no
because if they needed something else we
would have put it in yeah for sure
but no so to actually answer that
question one of one of the things people
do ask about a lot is like what
certification they should get and the
thing is like most of the certification
courses have most of the same
information and I think your best bet
honestly is just whatever gym you would
like to work at or whatever job you
would like to get in the fitness
industry just the person who would be
your boss if you got that job just go
into the gym and ask them like hey I am
interested in potentially getting a job
here what certifications do you like to
see from trainers you hire and whatever
they say those are the certs you get
because ultimately you will learn some
stuff in a certification course but the
biggest thing they give you from a
utilitarian perspective is they just
help you get your foot in the door so
whatever search you need to get that
foot in
door that's the one I would recommend
going for so that's you know actually
getting into the industry if you want to
actually be good at what you do I think
there you can learn some stuff from
reading and listening to people but I
think the best it's the the best
learning you can probably do is from
hands-on learning and observation of
people who know what they're doing
so if you can find a more experienced
coach or trainer who knows what they're
doing to take you under their wing is
like a mentor mentee relationship or
even like maybe a formal apprenticeship
position that would be great like that
you're there's a lot that you can't pick
up from a book that you pick up a lot
better from seeing someone wield the
craft that knows what they're doing so
I'd also strongly recommend that from a
knowledge acquisition perspective like I
said you'll probably learn some stuff in
a certification course but I strongly
recommend everyone read at least an
introductory anatomy and physiology and
exercise physiology textbook that's not
a super popular suggestion and I've been
recommending this for like seven or
eight years and I think maybe ten people
have actually done this but I mean I get
it like textbooks are boring but if you
read like they're like 600 pages long
ish read about 20 pages a day you get
through each one of them in a month
apiece and like that's not a 20 pages a
day and spending two months doing it
that's not an unrealistic amount of time
for you to invest to build a foundation
of knowledge that hopefully will help
you for the next thirty years so I'd
recommend just getting the basic
knowledge of the field of anatomy and
physiology and exercise physiology and
then to recommend some products that
aren't just shilling our own stuff I
think Eric Helms regrettably wrote some
good books in the muscle and strength
pyramid book so I even though we're
we're feuding with him and our
are very much upset with him from a
personal perspective I think his books
are actually quite good yeah you can
support a thing a person did without
supporting that person who they are or
everything else they did correct yes I
would add on to that almost kind of
reiterate the textbook recommendation is
not common or popular but it's the one
that I probably feel most strongly about
if you were to read I think one of the
best undergrad exfils textbooks is
bycatch and McCardle mm-hmm
if you were to read that reading a good
x fist textbook can get you so far in
terms of understanding what's going down
on the training side for sure so do you
want to lead off on our second closing
question what someone would recommend
for getting into exercise science in
exercise science program at a university
and what the biggest tips are for a
newbie who wants to get quote
big-brained that's a good question
certainly I can tell you what I did as
an exercise science student that I think
contributed most to like getting into
the program and doing relatively well
within it and for me that the first
thing was like if you really really love
exercise science that's going to help a
lot and it sounds stupid but a lot of
people in exercise science programs
don't actually like exercise science
they yeah they they view exercise
science as a very useful way to get a
very convenient group of prerequisite
courses done because what you'll find is
it especially I don't know about
internationally but in American higher
education if you get like an undergrad
Exercise Science degree and take one or
two courses extra you could go into like
almost any applied health field
you could do med school physical therapy
school you could go to a master's
program in the field I mean there there
are so many avenues you could take from
it that there are a lot of people who
are like I've talked to people it's like
Oh
what got you into exercise science no
like I just want to be a dentist man
like what and they're like yeah it's the
most convenient way to get the the
credits yeah like you you don't need
every class that you would take as like
a chemistry or biology major like some
of them are overkill but it's like take
exercise science and maybe add like
genetics and micro and depending on what
your school requires possibly o-chem if
that's not required for exercise science
and you're there yeah so I think having
passion for the actual field and the
content within is huge over studying is
huge so I had a professor I had a couple
professors that kind of teased me
because of how I over studied they're
kind of like make fun of me but it was
because I really enjoyed the material
and I wanted it to be in my brain for
the rest of my life mm-hm and so what I
would do is I would go take notes during
the class I would walk away from the
class and rewrite the notes again at the
library so I would just transcribe my
notes by hand once and then a second
time and then as I reviewed for the
final I would try to recreate those
notes from memory again writing in a
third time so like I over studied hard
and spent a lot of time in the library
just thinking about it and so the result
of that was there was one time where
this isn't even a good thing the
professor it was like multiple choice
and they're like which of these four
options it would be best and I was like
well based on the exact numbers you gave
for all of these in the lecture
technically it would fit between C and D
and he just kind of like sighed and
rolled his eyes and he's like dude just
just pick one come on but I was like
none of these are literally the exact
numbers you gave us last time which you
know I knew the the general it was like
a glycogen replenishment kind of thing
so like I knew that general premise but
I was like you know technically none of
these are the exact numbers and I was
like dude you suck so but like over
studying with obviously the intention is
to understand the themes and the
principles but the more you hammer at
home
the better I think and then spending
time and actually getting advice from
professors like I had a professor that I
was really close with and whenever I had
some random body building question that
excited me I would just show up to
office hours and I'd say oh no I'm good
on the class what do you think of this
and I don't know if they necessarily
loved it at first because they're like
you know they're busy they they have
like actual work [ __ ] to do
yeah but over time it became very
endearing that it was like you know what
I'm an exercise science professor and
during office hours while I'm here
someone's gonna come chat with me about
exercise science mm-hmm which is fun and
the more you develop those relationships
I you you engage more with the material
you enjoy the field more and you you
really reinforce that passion for it and
then when it when it comes down to it
having good relationships with
professors that are genuine those can
really help you out along the way like
you don't know be like the really
annoying person who's clearly trying to
get something from it like yeah that's
not engineering a lot of people do that
and I don't think they understand just
how transparent it is so so I I can I
can say say this is someone who's on the
opposite side of it a little bit now
like when I go to conferences at this
point like I am a known quantity there
are people who want to network with me
and it's it's painfully obvious within
two minutes of talking to someone if
they just like my work and they you know
just want to chat about something or if
they're just interested in making a
contact and they're absolutely going to
ask me for something within the next
like two months like no matter how
smooth you think you are it's probably
painfully obvious if you're you just in
indicate in these in this circumstance
here like just sucking up to a professor
for a recommendation letter like they're
gonna know they're gonna yeah it's like
what happens is like a lot of the
application processes are on like set
annual timelines
yeah and so it's always like four and a
half days before the due date like all
of a sudden that their their office
hours are attended like there's like a
twenty thousand percent increase in
attendance in every was like no I just
you know I love the class I figured I'd
drop by and see how you're doing
also I in an unrelated note I am indeed
applying to something yeah
so I that actually happened to me
applying to grad school a little bit so
the the department the the exercise
science department at the school I went
to had three professors and I was really
close with two of them like one of them
even before I graduated like I was on a
first-name basis with him he was fresh
out of school like we were we were
buddies like he came over to my house
for debt once I graduated and it wasn't
weird anymore like he came over and like
visited us and like brought his family
and we ate dinner together he invited me
over to his house just to hang out so I
was super close with him I was pretty
close with one of the other professors
he was he was a track coach and he
personally was into bodybuilding and
strength training so like we would talk
about training quite a bit the third
professor man we didn't dislike each
other but we just had very different
personalities so like I tried to get to
know him and it was just kind of painful
and then when it came time to apply for
grad school
most of the schools I applied to wanted
two letters of recommendations but the
ones that wanted three I was like [ __ ]
like I was gonna go and this was like a
small school I think there were 30
people in exercise science in my
graduating class and so you know even in
that type of situation and and I mean I
was a good student so he did I assume
write me a good letter of recommendation
but you know I I was even a little bit
uncomfortable with asking one of those
professors for a letter so if you're if
you're at a big school it probably takes
more effort to get on professors radars
in the first place
and three letters of recommendation is
quite a bit like it takes some effort to
actually form a relationship with three
professors like that especially if
they're super busy my chemistry class
that I took had like 600 people and if
the professor forgot the microphone or
it wasn't working we didn't try so like
yeah in a class like that or at a
university that's pretty big you it's
probably not a bad idea even if it's not
completely in line with your preferences
to just sit up front and center make
sure you stay on task mm-hmm say hey
when you enter the room say hey when you
leave stop by the office when you need
something even that alone goes a long
way but like if you feel uncomfortable
asking someone for a recommendation
letter that probably means you didn't
put in the amount of face time that you
you ought to have put in yeah so the
other recommendations that I would add
were one if you're in high school like
if you're still in high school and are
maybe like a junior and you're thinking
about applying to college to go the
exercise science route make sure you get
good grades and try to get as many
scholarships as you can because college
is getting more expensive I'm assuming
I'm talking to Americans here College is
getting more expensive substantially so
year over year and most of the jobs that
you're gonna get fresh out of school
with an Exercise Science degree don't
pay all that well so the more you can
minimize the amount of student loans you
have to take out the better so yeah like
start doing the work now to try to apply
for every scholarship you can getting as
good of grades as possible to hopefully
get some merit scholarships that's huge
like you don't want to be twenty-two
years old coming out of school without a
job yet and fifty grand in debt and you
you said that you're assuming you're
talking to people in America even though
you know very well that our audience is
largely not from America it's like fifty
percent from America right so if you're
not from America which is a decent
percentage if this make
no sense to you you should be very glad
that this makes no sense to you this is
student loans in America are as you
would say Eric mental at this point very
mental okay so the next thing so Eric
gave some recommendations based on the
assumption that you are actually doing
the basic stuff and you are studying
enough to over study but I mean one of
the things that when I was going through
school there I mean there were probably
ten of us that took a bunch of the same
classes together that all tended to get
pretty good grades and then the other
like two-thirds of the class all tended
to struggle a lot and the biggest
difference honestly was just that we
were the ones that sat in the front of
every class like Eric mentioned you
actually take notes there are a lot of
people who just don't take notes which
blows my mind again if you're American
and you're pain like $700 per credit
hour to be in that class you're paying
probably twenty-one twenty-two hundred
bucks a class like use that time take
notes like so you can hopefully retain
what was said in the lectures and then
the other big thing is actually doing
the reading like most classes have
assigned reading from a textbook and a
lot of people will just rely on what is
said in the lectures and then if you
have a few test questions that you know
we're from the readings you were
supposed to do but not from the textbook
like professors will slip those into a
lot of tests to see who is actually
doing everything they're supposed to for
the course and so many people don't ever
read their textbooks so like read your
[ __ ] textbooks and then if it's a
small enough class to have class
discussions people retain information
better if it's participatory so you know
not trying to you know be an annoying
trihard and the person who's talking
with the professor the whole time in
class but if there is class discussion
if you participate in it
you will probably retain that
information better because if there is
an active participatory element to
learning
retention is a little bit better then in
addition to what Eric was saying about
over studying two things that I would
strongly recommend are one try to study
a little bit over time instead of having
to cram the night before the test in
that and also go back and look at notes
from classes you're never going to have
to take a test for again so if for
example your program has to exercise
physiology classes and you took X phys
one last semester and you're taking X
fizz to the semester at some point
during the semester like three or four
times just go back and review your notes
from X phys one even though you're not
going to be tested on that one that
helps make sure the foundation is still
there for the material you're currently
learning and to the the longer
information sticks in your head the more
likely it will be to stick in your head
in perpetuity so if a class runs for
four months and you know you study for
the final and whatnot and you kind of
remember the stuff that you learned four
months ago like that's cool but that
could be totally out of your head in
five years but if you take a class and
then eighteen months later you take
another class and you're reviewing the
notes from the class you took eighteen
years ago and you review them often
enough that when you look through those
notes all of the information still makes
sense and is still fresh in your head
once you've retained information for
eighteen months couple years that is
probably going to stick for several more
years after that point so just going
back and reviewing old stuff that you
don't have to review to get grades
tomorrow is going to set you up really
well for the next you know 10 or 20
years and in general if you're
interested in learning and getting good
grades just over all and this will help
you really with pretty much any subject
you want to learn in life I would
recommend a review paper by Soderstrom
at all called learning versus
performance and integrative review it's
a it's a pretty straightforward paper to
read it's going to be useful it's going
to be interesting to fitness people
as well because it talks about both like
learning knowledge but also motor
learning and how those two things are
are related to each other and principles
that are kind of Universal in the
learning process
and so a key thing to note is that
learning and performance are different
so a rough definition of learning is
acquiring knowledge or skill that you
can use again at a later date and
performance is just how well you can do
today basically and so I think a lot of
people and and this is where like over
studying is interesting so if you take
notes from a class look over the notes a
couple times you may know everything
that is on those notes and if you look
at a fourth time they will look just as
comfortable and fresh as when you looked
at them the third time and you're like
well okay I'm done learning this
material it's all in there it sticks so
at that point your performance is good
your knowledge of the notes at that
point in time is quite good continuing
to review them isn't acutely improving
your performance when reviewing the
notes but learning and like long-term
retention does benefit from over
studying so it's kind of like if you are
a musician and you're trying to learn a
difficult piece of music you practice
that piece of music you get to the point
that you can play it perfectly and if
you get to the point that you can play
it perfectly
once your performance is as good as it
can be you performed it perfectly one
time but that doesn't mean you've
necessarily learned it if you are
learned it super well if you get to the
point that you can play it perfectly
twenty times in a row your performance
isn't improving as you keep practicing
it those additional 19 times but then if
you have to play that piece of music
again next week you will play it better
from having played it perfectly 20 times
than having played it once
so performance didn't continue improving
but learning did continue to occur and
so I think a lot of people do
tend to under study they study to the
point that when I look at my notes right
now they look good they all make sense
to me and they don't keep studying for
you know a substantial amount of
additional time to make sure it's really
really gonna stick so that's like one of
the principles from that Soderstrom
review another thing that is also super
super useful when it comes to learning
virtually any subject is taking tests
and so people view test taking as
something different from the learning
process but test taking is actually a
really good way to learn something
because it forces you to engage kind of
more forcefully with the material it's
easy to passively read over notes think
like oh okay like this kind of all makes
sense but then when it comes time to
actually take a quiz or test and the
rubber meets the road you have to think
about each question and so the
information you already know it forces
you to think a little bit harder about
it to make sure you can put the correct
answer on the test so that helps further
ingrain the stuff you already know and
the stuff you don't know it forces you
to become acutely aware of the fact you
don't know it so then you know how to do
more targeted studying moving forward so
if like whatever subject you're trying
to learn if you can go online and find
like an old test or quiz over that type
of information doing that before you
start actually studying it and a couple
times during the studying process that
will help you learn and retain
information better than you will just
from kind of passively studying and
reading over notes but that's that I
think that's one of the keys that's one
of the things that there's the most
research supporting that it being super
super good for learning like taking
tests testing yourself testing your
ability testing your knowledge as part
of the learning process there's a ton of
research to verify its efficacy but no
one does that when they're studying like
that that's one of that's something that
ever
one can do to make studying more
effective and efficient definitely I
have two last things to add here my
program was weird I didn't get into
exercise science coursework until the
third year of college because they
wouldn't let us and which is okay I like
the program overall it was a really nice
program but I did a lot of outside
reading before I got my formal
coursework in exercise science so if you
like haven't started college yet this
would apply to you big-time and what I
found was a lot of that outside just
like evidence-based fitness reading
really gave me a nice foundation to
build on and then once I was in the
coursework it made me wrestle with
topics that I was learning in class in a
different context mm-hm and that's a
huge part of learning as well is being
able to translate not just the exact
verbage that you're hearing but making
you wrestle with the principles and
apply it to other situations mm-hmm so
like I think keeping up with your
outside interests in exercise science is
huge when you become an exercise science
student like like you're your
non-academic interest in exercise
science related to things it is a really
nice complementary thing to keep in the
mix and then finally when you're
studying as a student you know you could
view it as you've got a test coming up
what's the bare minimum score you could
live with
and so you could operationalize your
studying as the purpose here is to get
at least X percent on this upcoming exam
mm-hmm but more importantly I think it
makes more sense depending on what your
goals are like I would imagine when you
were studying for exams in your
undergrad and graduate coursework you
are probably thinking how is this
information gonna make me better at
doing Fitness things for the rest of my
career
correct how am I going to use this to
establish not the perception of
expertise but actual expertise in this
field right like it's about learning the
material and being able to use it
proficiently for the next four
years it's not just like I got to get
like a 90 so if you use that as your
framework for how you view learning I
think it's going to make a huge huge
difference I also just think the I think
the level people shoot for matters a lot
as well like if you're if you're trying
to learn information so just if you do
want to focus on grades for example if
if this is information that you think
you're going to be using for the next 30
40 years for your career you shouldn't
really be shooting for B's and just
grades that are good enough like the
number you should be shooting for is a
hundred percent on everything you do and
like obviously that's that's overkill
like you don't need that to graduate or
graduate with honors or anything like
that
but your goal shouldn't be to graduate
with the degree the goal should be to
learn everything well so you can use it
for the next 30 or 40 years so like you
know obviously being perfect at
everything is an unrealistic standard
but I don't think that it's an
unreasonable goal to aim for because I
mean ultimately that's what is going to
be more likely to set you up for success
10 20 years from now yeah I mean you
know in chemistry I would get grades and
be like yeah alright like on my x phys
exams at every level of schooling if I
got like a 98 because I missed one out
of 50 I would look at that question I'd
be like god this is so embarrassing
ya know same for sure yeah like you
should I mean I don't want to like
reflect my I'm a bit mental I don't want
to encourage people to be that way but
like I honestly felt like if I missed
three out of a hundred questions I was
embarrassed three times like I felt I
would internalize that which is probably
not healthy but also is like you're
gonna learn [ __ ] if that's your natural
visceral reaction to getting something
wrong no III was the exact same way and
if I missed a question I was gonna beat
myself up about it
yeah and I was going to like dig into my
notes right then and try to figure out
how I failed myself by not acquiring the
knowledge necessary to answer that
question right yeah and that's really
important you were beating yourself up
you weren't bothering your poor
professors saying that their question
was stupid that's a really key component
there I mean sometimes I did I'm sure he
did if it was a stupid question yeah
that's fair sometimes there are stupid
questions I mean and another thing to
note is like if you are someone who's
kind of wired to be a perfectionist
there's I feel I I feel like that's
generally unhealthy but it can it can be
more or it can be useful or not useful
like just beating yourself up about it
doesn't help you with much but beating
yourself up to try to figure out like
how you cannot do something wrong in the
future and then making like tangible
changes to reduce your risk of making
the same mistake again can be quite
useful big time all right well I think
that does it for this week's episode do
you have anything to add before we sign
off the whole thing with knowledge bombs
and knowledge anthrax and all that [ __ ]
that was a bit it's the dumbest [ __ ]
expression we we were trying to
highlight that in this episode and
please never say it in our presence ever
again I won't be mad at you but I will I
will
slightly judge you I think that's fair
to say yeah okay alright but even if you
use that phrase we still love you thank
you so much for listening take care if
you have questions for future episodes
be sure to find those links in the
description of this episode you can
submit those questions via Facebook
Instagram or Twitter threads thanks for
listening and we'll see you next time
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now Greg and I are not
experts in medicine or health or really
anything else for that matter so before
you make any changes to your
diet and exercise habits make sure you
check with a doctor or another
healthcare professional if you enjoyed
this podcast and you'd like to support
it visit stronger by science comm to
check out the products and services that
we offer thanks for listening and we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you